we had a great meeting yesterday with
Nancy Pelosi and Senator Schumer and it
was a very bipartisan meeting we could
have done a longer deal but that would
have affected the military as you know
so we're really kept it for three months
because of the military we have a great
respect for the sanctity of the debt
ceiling and Chuck does and then she does
and we all do so that will never be a
problem that ceiling will never be a
problem that was President Trump earlier
today talking about the deal that he
made with congressional Democrats on the
debt ceiling which will prevent a
government shutdown at the end of the
month and many Republicans are
reportedly livid with the compromise but
didn't the president get to the White
House that he promised to be a deal
maker is this a good deal joining us now
with reaction
editor-in-chief life-debt Fox News
contributor nationally syndicated radio
host and I don't have enough time for
the rest of the introduction or Ingraham
we all know all right but before I get
to that question I want to get back to
the hurricane issue now we believe in
limited government but the biggest
criticism the left had was Milania shoes
which was pretty despicable in and of
itself you know I called over to the
White House today I found out they have
pre-positioned troops food water
medicine supplies cots blankets baby
formula
they have general mattis ordered for
Navy ships and they have thousands of
people on the call on the ready right
now so where are we going with their
criticism this time when government is
actually working well the left and many
Republicans many never Trump errs Shawn
are loath to recognize anything that
works well in the administration except
maybe if we're getting involved in
another war they'll be happy with that
some of the never Trump errs but other
than that they will not acknowledge and
nor should President Trump wait for the
acknowledgement that in the face of the
worst natural disaster to befall our
country which it looks like this
hurricane is going to be the the Trump
administration do did everything
possible to coordinate on a federal
state and local level
be prepared in a way that I think is
really it's admirable it's it's it's
smart it's it's what government really
should do at a time like this but I
don't think we should hold our breath
waiting for any acknowledgment of that I
don't think president Trump cares about
that at this point he's worried about
the people in South Florida all up all
the way to Tallahassee the Gainesville
it's going to be a monster storm the
hill advantage going to the Carolinas
yeah it this is a scary moment yeah you
would think that's what we want we want
to help out our friends in Texas now our
friends in Florida we want them safe and
secure the fact that they you know thank
God we have you know meteorology that
can tell us storms like this are coming
and and then of course we make the
necessary preparations let me go to this
compromise deal I actually agree with
newts analysis and that the president
wanted to get the money to Texas and
that was a big part of his rationale in
thinking and with all due respect to
Mitch McConnell he hasn't exactly proven
himself capable of doing anything
because expectations are so high
especially on health care yeah Sean all
the caterwauling were hearing from
Republicans of oh woe is us look we're
betrayed where was all of their concern
and urgency over the last six weeks
they took off for the August recess they
went home they did what they do at home
they went to some picnics and some state
fairs probably raised some money took a
little break and at the time I think the
president begins to think we got to get
something done here we he wants to be a
popular president he is a conservative
populist that means at times if
Republicans don't deliver legislation
that he can sign on the critical matters
that he campaigned on he's going to look
to move the ball down the field with you
know another set of players and
sometimes it's going to be people that
you and I don't like very much we don't
agree with on many issues on an issue
like the debt ceiling which is a
conservative concern and rightfully so
but the president wanted to move this
issue off the table and clear the deck
for tax reform if they do not get tax
reform done they're done they're
finished and Paul Ryan candidate
potential I think had an extra-special
spring in his step I think today on tax
reform II that's funny what uh
working with the new Bratz will do to
the Republicans ohoo McConnell
I didn't hear who use I and Ryan Ryan
had a little extra extra excitement
about the teza
I'm going to be fair it at least Ryan
got the health care bill out of the
house and the freedom caucus worked hard
with him and they got it done at the end
of the day look this is the makalah is
no excuses and the fact that he feels so
much pressure and excessive expectations
is my number
yeah when should when Charlotte's Ville
happened these people are the first ones
to give you no baton background or
off-the-record sniping at the president
a lot of these people who are or
grousing now about about Donald Trump
they're happy to say oh he doesn't
understand how complex things are he
doesn't understand how difficult
legislation is and he comes along and
says you know something if you don't
work with me I'm going to work with
these other people we're going to get
something there versus you were the same
thing people like Ben Sasse and and
flake and John McCain other things they
say about him behind closed doors they
hate rock okay Laura Ingraham great to
see you thank you to being with us